some breaking news here in Germany
thieves have reportedly pulled off a
spectacular heist at one of Europe's
most renowned museums police in Dresden
say the break-in at the green vaults of
the city's royal palace took place in
the early hours of Monday morning police
haven't yet confirmed what exactly has
been stolen but the loot apparently
includes three priceless sets of
jewellery Dresden's prized collection of
historical treasures includes crown
jewels and bowls carved out of crystal
and we have our correspondents following
the latest on this story for STW smacks
ammonia Koscheck is with us and Scott
Roxboro here in studio good to have you
both max let's start with you
authorities have been holding a press
conference what more do we know about
what happened yes so authorities have so
far been trying to reconstruct the heist
that was taking place in the early hours
of Monday morning they've been able to
obtain some video footage from the
museum to look at how the heist has
happened and so far what we know is that
at around 5 a.m. in the morning the
security system was alerted and that the
security services have been giving the
alert further to the police authorities
and according to the footage that police
authorities have been now looking at two
suspects have been entering the jewelery
room which is one of 10 rooms of their
green vault this priced treasure
chambers interest and they've been
entering the jeweler room through a
window breaking in and then aiming
straight for one cabinet where
jewelleries have been on display they
have been taking as far as we know three
complete jewellery sets so that is like
a set of jewelry collections and they
have been taking three of those as a
complete set and then left a probably by
car authorities now suspect and am
leaving over the highway so police have
now installed Highway Patrol's trying to
find those suspects and also been
talking to Berlin authorities here in
the capital because in 2017 another very
spectacular heist has been taking place
not far from the German government
district in the ball
and hundred kilogram gold coin had been
stolen in broad daylight
so now authorities indrasen are talking
to the authorities in Berlin to see if
there's any connection to the both hice
Scott let's talk about this collection
because it has an impressive history
tell us more about this collection yeah
I mean this is sort of comparable to
something like the crown jewels in in in
London I mean this was a collection it
was created by August the strong august
ii who set up in the late in the early
18th century 1723 - 1730 and he was sort
of in competition with louis xiv in
france to try and create the most
extravagant impressive opulent
collection of jewelry and and and and
priceless goods and so this collection
that's one almost unique in the world
it's an incredible treasure trove and
the they made the point that these
pieces of course are very valuable that
have been stolen but they're their
actual value and historical value it is
completely priceless thing and cannot be
measured a lot of people are probably
wondering how such an exquisite
collection could have been targeted at
all and police have been talking about
that as well in their press conference
about the theft let's listen in what's
clear to us is that the perpetrators
entered the building through a window
facing Palace square they cut through
the bars on the window and smashed the
glass they then targeted a specific
display case which they shattered they
then fled the building and disappeared
we don't take the boy to house all right
max coming back to you you were
listening in to the press conference
what more did police say about how such
of that could have happened yes so
police authorities as well as securities
are quite flabbergasted that this house
could have been taking place now the
green world has been a treasure trove
for over 300 years and so nothing in
that sort had happened before some have
compared the security measures at the
Greenwald similar to Fort Knox the
u.s. American treasure chamber where
they keep the gold reserves of the
United States and one thing that seems
to be particular about the kc of the
heist and dressen is that the
perpetrators seemed to have been able to
damage the electricity box that was
connected to the alarm system they've
been using a fire to damage that box
that then caused the fire electricity
outage in the museum and therefore
didn't make the alarm go off as far as
we know by the authorities all right and
Scott listening to that you know what
does happen now it's a it's a big
question I mean the pieces are
incredibly well known of this the this
work is incredibly well known so selling
it on the open market for the thieves
would probably impossible at least
that's what the art historians hope
theoretically they these pieces could be
broken down and sold for their value as
diamonds but we heard today from the
press conference that that would be a
fraction of their their true value
another possibility that was raised
though there's no evidence that this is
going to happen is that the thieves
could try to auction this jewelry back
to the state of dread of Saxon to have
them buy back their treasures any of
this is is possible we hope though that
of course these pieces will be recovered
in their original state and that they
will pretty store it to their rightful
place at the Museum yeah meanwhile the
investigations continue all right our
correspondent sir Scott broxbourne
studio and Maximiliano Koscheck thank
you both